non-minimalists
i don't remember i was doing some prep
for this episode i don't know if this
was in your book or i was just reading
it somewhere else
uh the dieter row effect are you
familiar with the detoro effect i'm not
okay so i've i got the definition here
obtaining a new possession often creates
a spiral of consumption which leads you
to acquire
more new things uh a different
philosopher name uh i forget his first
name but dietero
what's his name so basically when we we
buy something
i think of the the example like if you
buy a really nice piece of furniture but
you have a bunch of crappy furniture at
home
now all of a sudden you're like oh now
now all this other stupid furniture
uh in fact i see this right now this is
the ditoro effect when we're in this
temporary studio space
which thank god we're going to be out of
soon um but as soon as
we've started building out our new space
it makes me even want to be out of this
space
even more because the new space is
beautiful we're working with a set
designer
and now every time i see one of our
youtube videos that are filmed in here
i'm like
yeah that was fine for a period of time
but like it's not like the new space
right
and so as a result we end up buying
things that our previous selves
never needed to feel happy or fulfilled
so
that that's the dietero effect where we
consume one thing
but it's almost like uh well what what
is a good metaphor for this like if you
um
if you just get like if you drink
something that makes you thirstier in a
way something that's like
a diuretic now all of a sudden you need
to drink more and more and
consumerism is obviously an unquenchable
thirst
but but the detero effect shows that
quite often it can turn into this this
domino effect that first purchase
as innocuous or anodyne as it might seem
at the time
leads us to desiring a whole bunch of
other things
is there do you know anything about what
might be behind that phenomena
well i'm hearing this for the first time
but the first thing that it makes me
think of
is the reflexivity of desire and kind of
the reflexivity
of reality itself what i mean by
reflexiveness
just that the the act of like
moving to some new reality like you know
you you drink
the soda or the diuretic or the caffeine
or whatever
um after you've done that
you're not in the position that you were
in before
and the the the the new reality
is is is different so you have to
evaluate it by
completely different standards yes so
it's almost as if so the
reflexivity of desires is like if we're
all on the same
trampoline and you know one person jumps
or one person
moves right there's just no way that
it's not going to affect
us in in some way so this is true of
physics but
it's also true to our our desires right
like it's constantly
um we're not neutral observers to these
things
right we're like caught up in it and
we're affected in
in real time so we can't stand back and
make calculations about
what we think will make us happy because
the next day when we wake up
reality is different and it's so easy to
forget about that
yeah the ditoro effect and for me it
kind of puts an accent on the saying
uh comparison is the killer of joy
because that's really what's happening
right right you have some
you buy a new thing and now you're
comparing it to everything else right
and and that's really um
that's what this whole conversation
about memetic desire is it's about
these comparisons that we're constantly
doing yeah in our last film
less is now on netflix they talk about
or annie
she talked about the vertical expansion
of our reference group
which is a fancy way of talking about
keeping up with the joneses basically
right so
this comparison being the thief of joy
all of a sudden your neighbor gets
the new mustang or we're in la the new
lamborghini
and uh now all of a sudden it's like oh
i didn't know i needed a lamborghini
but now i need the lamborghini even
though i i know
intellectually i don't but there's
something in me that feels as though i
do
and so in a way now though we're
comparing ourselves to every
everyone we've never met it's on on our
instagram feeds it's on television it's
on the billboards it's on the four to
ten thousand ads we see
every day we're comparing ourselves and
our desires the memetic desires are
created
by our culture and the detero effect is
simply
saying well be careful about what you
bring into your life because it might
make you want to bring
other things into your life it'll make
you start
comparing other things that you didn't
compare before you know you use the
lamborghini example
but i think it's even worse when it's
something that we actually can afford
like i look at um yeah i'm not on
facebook anymore
you know how someone you know someone
quit facebook don't worry they'll tell
you
but i remember uh a certain um
old friend of ours a professional
wrestler
him and his wife got a hellcat which is
like it's a it's a very fast i think
dodge is what it is
and yeah long story short i'm not even
into sports cars
but because i look up to that friend
that old friend so much and his wife
like they got a great relationship they
got a kid i mean
i in a lot of ways envy their life and
they get the hellcat and now i'm like
well that's within reach do i need to
get a hellcat like i could totally i
might be able to afford a hellcat
payment
so it's it's interesting like when yeah
when we see those things and i think
that's why social media is so dangerous
because there are so many
solutions on there that are within our 5
10
15 20 you know maybe 100 reach that
isn't
it's not like a lamborghini it's a lot
easier to obtain
and we see it everywhere like we see it
in the feed we see it when you hop on
instagram all of a sudden
there are so many things that are it
makes it accessible but just because
something is accessible doesn't mean
it's going to improve your life well the
things that are more accessible
are frankly more dangerous and i think
lead to more of the ditero effect
so think about it like this like if you
ask most people like who are you more
jealous of or who are you paying more
attention to
in terms of what they get and what they
want jeff bezos
or like the person that lives next door
that works in a similar industry
that just happened to get a new car yeah
it's going to be the second person
right because like proximity matters and
accessibility
matters and those are more powerful
models to us
than the kind that are kind of outside
of our world that seem to exist in a
different sphere
sometimes these can be our friends as
you said ryan i mean
the closer that people are to us the
more similar they are to us
the more kind of powerful hold they have
over us and the more we care
about what they want did you enjoy this
video if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists today
your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel 100
advertisement free